Oh,
for less than 24 hours,
there was a challenge to Russia's leadership by a private army who has played a key role in
Russia's invasion of Ukraine.
Here's how it unfolded late Friday in Russia,
the leader of the Wagner group,
Yevgeni Pri Goin claimed that the Russian military killed an enormous amount of his
troops in an artillery strike and that his forces were going to cross into Russia
calling it the March of justice Russia responded by issuing an arrest
warrant for Pri Goshen for mutiny denying his claims and a heavy
military presence appeared in Moscow.
By early Saturday morning,
Wagner forces were seen in Rostov 600 miles south.
It's the main logistical hub for Russian forces operating in Ukraine.
Pri Gozin said that his forces had taken the city
in a televised address.
Russian President Vladimir Putin responded and called for his military to stop the
revolt.
Residents of Rostov stocked up on gas and cleared grocery store shelves.
Meanwhile,
Wagner vehicles were on the move.
They went along the M four highway which goes northward straight to Moscow
where roadblocks began going up about halfway 300 miles
from Moscow in Veronis Russian military helicopters opened fire on them.
A warehouse and fuel tanks were destroyed and Wagar forces reportedly shot down
six Russian helicopters and a plane.
Wagner forces continued to move north but by the time they were within 125
miles of Moscow,
a deal was reached,
the advance was over brokered by the president of Belarus.
According to a Putin spokesman,
the charges against Gozin will be dropped and he will move to the neighboring country,
an armed confrontation that lasted less than 24 hours.